han denunciado ustedes la detención de
varios integrantes de su organización
cuéntenos de quiénes se tratan qué
sucedió y cómo es en estos momentos el
estado de situación
si la situación es sumamente alarmante
ayer por la noche hubo redadas
policiales a lo largo del país en
diferentes territorios por parte de la
unidad nacional azul y blanco en nuestro
monitoreo de incidencia recibimos la
denuncia de la detención de al menos
ocho miembros de nuestra organización de
entre entre los cuales se encuentran los
coordinadores de los funcionarios
principales y consejos departamentales
de chinandega pero también miembro de
los comités tos en managua uno de ellos
es wamar vado el joven dirigente del
distrito 1 en managua esos son digamos
sólo algunas de las personas detenidas
que es en los reportes álex han
cuestionado lo que está ocurriendo en
costa rica en esta jornada de protestas
que se llevan a cabo además en otros
países en contra de las elecciones
nicaragüenses
si nosotros hemos hecho un llamado esto
es parte del llamado a la protesta
cívica que nosotros como oposición hemos
hecho le hemos pedido a la ciudadanía
nicaragüense que se abstenga de asistir
a los centros de votación para no
legitimar la farsa mientras miles de
nicaragüenses nos manifestamos en las
calles y capitales de diferentes partes
del mundo en repudio a esta farsa
electoral y exigiendo justicia y
democracia en nicaragua la marcha y
estas movilizaciones han sido un rotundo
éxito han asistido personas de
diferentes organizaciones de la
oposición y
sumamente esperanzador ver a los
nicaragüenses alrededor del mundo y
movilizándose por una causa común y
precisamente sobre esto yo quisiera
preguntar recién adelantaba algo maneja
información sobre el nivel de
participación
si nosotros hemos estado trabajando de
cerca con una organización
llamada urnas abiertas y se nos ha
reportado que el nivel de abstención ha
sido
bastante alto no ve la foto que todavía
no tenemos la cifra específica esas las
vamos a tener aproximadamente dentro de
una media hora pero si la el reporte de
incidencia y monitoreo de territorios
los ha arrojado pues información de que
el nivel de abstención es sumamente alto
hay juntas receptoras de votos donde es
bueno en la mayoría no hay filas pero
donde no hay asistentes y además de todo
se ven intactas digamos las actas de
votación